coach as one of the greatest point
guards you've seen players have games
like this where they score 50 points 50
plus points and you know just the feed
him but when it's your point guard and
as a coach is it just all right I'm
going just let him just go with it
instead of whether he's going away from
the game plan or not when he's that hot
no he is the game plan um
so some say they're the system he is the
game plan and so um again his ability to
uh make shots create shots uh fine open
guys um he did that at a high level
tonight um again uh early on you know
when he was going you could see that he
wasn't falling and and and he was on his
feet so I thought his foundation his
base was really good tonight he had his
legs it looked like um and he just took
what the defense gave him um again
trying to keep everyone involved I
thought Timmy make some big threes out
of the double team where we got the
Swing Swing again the trust when you are
going like that a lot of times you can
say hey I'm just going to beat the
double team and shoot it um I've gotten
the team this far but again that's who
he is he's unselfish and he put his
teammates in a position to be successful
tonight